you're the executive producer on these
Housewives shows yeah okay
yes you they must view you as a god
because you literally control their
lives uh yeah you know yeah there's
there's there are different
relationships we all have and sometimes
it's like a daddy thing and sometimes
it's a really no a daddy in a good way
oh not like a creepy daddy no no daddy
with sexy hair Deborah
yes yes daddy was sexy hair yeah yeah
but I mean it must be kind of strange
where you can literally decide do they
stay on the show do they not stay tuned
in I mean you have a kind of godlike
power I've tried to fire just about
everybody here and they just don't
listen to me everything they have it's
right I have no power on this show
really yeah Wow but you I mean you can
just change these people's lives by
saying you no longer amuse me okay well
it's really it's really kind of up to
the viewers to tell you the truth but
yes it is it isn't interesting it's an
it's an interesting dynamic yeah
you